The Clone Wars-era Ahsoka Tano has finally made
her live-action debut — and you might have noticed
she was played by a familiar face. So who is
Ariana Greenblatt, the actor who played her?
Like many young actors before her, Ariana
Greenblatt got her start working on the
small screen — and, before long, she became
one of the faces of the Disney Channel. After
playing a few minor roles in Disney shows,
Greenblatt's big break came courtesy of
the sitcom Stuck in the Middle, which ran
for three seasons between 2016 and 2018.
Stuck in the Middle sees Greenblatt play
Daphne Diaz, the youngest sibling in a
family with six children. The character
is known for vandalizing her dolls,
her unique sense of style, and her
precocious nature. Speaking to J-14,
Greenblatt said that she imagines Daphne will
grow up to start her own business — and that
it'll probably involve dolls. Spin-off?
It hasn't happened yet, but who knows?
While Stuck in the Middle boasts an
all-star cast — including a young Jenna
Ortega — Greenblatt's unique character
and impressive performance helped her to
stand out from the pack. It seems she was
always destined for big things, however,
and it didn't take long for the actress to get
offered movie roles after the Disney sitcom ended.
Shortly after catching her big break
on the small screen, Ariana Greenblatt
landed her first feature film role, starring
in the 2017 comedy A Bad Moms Christmas. The
sequel to 2016's Bad Moms follows a group
of overburdened mothers who are forced to
contend with their own parents during the
holiday season. Hijinks ensue, of course.
In the movie, Greenblatt plays Lori Harkness,
the daughter of Jay Hernandez and Mila Kunis'
characters. In one of the film's funniest scenes,
Lori confronts her mother about the strange
noises and foul language that she hears coming
out of her parent's bedroom, which results
in an awkward exchange between the pair.
In an interview with Bionic Buzz, Greenblatt
said that she loved working with her co-stars,
adding that collaborating with them was
the highlight of the entire shoot. But
while A Bad Moms Christmas gave her the
chance to show off her comedic chops,
Greenblatt was about to make a big
leap into a very different franchise…
"What did it cost you?"
"Everything."
Ariana Greenblatt's outing as the young
Jedi Ahsoka Tano isn't the first time
that she's played a younger version of
a formidable hero in a hugely popular
franchise. Prior to starring on Ahsoka,
she portrayed young Gamora in Avengers:
Infinity War, featuring in a pair of
scenes alongside Josh Brolin's Thanos.
Greenblatt's big moment occurs when Thanos and
his forces invade the young Gamora's home planet.
Despite her best efforts to fight off some of the
villain's minions, she can't resist his offer of
help. Thus begins a dysfunctional father-daughter
relationship that, ultimately, ends in tragedy.
Most actors would do anything to be part of the
Star Wars and Marvel franchises.
And it seems that Greenblatt can
now tick both off her list — despite the
fact her career is just getting started.
Based on Katherine Alice Applegate's
novel of the same name, The One and
Only Ivan tells the story of a gorilla
who teams up with an elephant to escape
from captivity. Ariana Greenblatt plays
Julia, an artistically driven child who
develops a bond with the ape through
their shared sense of loneliness.
This role struck a chord with the young actress
at the time. During a conversation with the Movie
Times, Greenblatt explained that she was already
a fan of the book prior to landing the part. In
the same interview, Greenblatt also opened up
about what attracted her to the role of Julia
in the first place. According to the actress,
she identified with the character due to their
mutual love of animals and drawing —
making it quite the fun role to play.
In 2020, Ariana Greenblatt landed a supporting
role in Netflix's post-apocalyptic creature
flick Love and Monsters. The story centers around
Joel Dawson and his loyal canine friend as they
embark on an adventure to reunite with Joel's high
school sweetheart. This adventure brings them into
contact with a cast of fascinating characters,
including Greenblatt's survivalist expert, Minnow.
One of the film's standout characters, Minnow
accompanies Michael Rooker's character, Clyde,
in his quest to find a safe haven in
the harsh wastelands. They're both
portrayed as experts at surviving in the ravaged
new world and work together to overcome
the monstrous threats that dwell there.
"What you so scared for?
The older snails are nice."
"There can be nice ones?"
This is arguably one of Greenblatt's most mature
roles to date, as her character is one who has
experienced some tough times during her short
life. She also capably holds her own alongside
veteran actor Rooker, making their characters
feel more like equals than an adult-child pairing.
Awake tells the story of a catastrophic event
that simultaneously takes away humankind's
ability to fall asleep and shuts off all of the
world's electronics. With the world trapped in
a state of insomnia-induced hysteria and no
means to recharge, people gradually become
more and more unhinged, forcing scientists to
come up with a solution before time runs out.
Ariana Greenblatt plays Matilda in Awake, a child
who, as one of the few who is able to sleep,
might hold the key to humankind's salvation.
However, this puts her in considerable danger,
as some people want to sacrifice her;
meanwhile, Matilda's mother wants to keep
her alive at all costs and come up with
an alternative solution to the problem.
While Awake didn't exactly receive heaps of
critical acclaim, Greenblatt's performance
certainly caught Hollywood's attention, as she
moved on to a number of other noteworthy projects
afterward. And the actress credits this one as
one of her favorite roles, telling Unpublished
Zine that it allowed her to showcase more acting
range than ever before at the time. She said:
"This role really pushed me and shows
an emotional range and it is very
action-packed which is something I've
never done before. It was so much fun."
An adaptation of Lin-Manuel Miranda's first hit
stage musical, In the Heights hit theaters in
2021. The film follows Usnavi, a New York City
bodega owner who dreams about living a better
life. He wants to go back to his native
Dominican Republic, so he saves up his
pennies in the hope of realizing that ambition.
Greenblatt plays the younger version of Nina,
a lead character who returns home from college
to spend the summer in the neighborhood.
The musical genre turned out to be a good fit
for Greenblatt. While she doesn't have one of
the main roles in In The Heights, her history
as a dancer makes her perfect for roles of this
ilk. During a conversation with Elle, she said
that she's been dancing for most of her life,
so it wouldn't be surprising if she tackles
more roles in this genre down the line. In
the meantime, fans who want to check out
Greenblatt's skills can also revisit her
tenure on Dancing with the Stars, where
she finished as a fourth-placed runner-up.
"I'm feeling so excited, a little nervous, but
I'm very ready to meet my partner. Let's go!"
Ariana Greenblatt has apparently developed
something of a taste for post-apocalyptic
movies. But while most of them have
been sci-fi stories set in the future,
one of her most recent roles is
set 65 billion years in the past.
In 65, the actress plays Koa, a survivor of a
catastrophic event who must team up with Adam
Driver's Mills to survive a land of dinosaurs.
Cue an adventure that's reminiscent of The Last
of Us with elements of Jurassic Park and
A Quiet Place thrown in for good measure.
Some critics lambasted 65 as a dino-bore that
failed to live up to its intriguing premise,
but Greenblatt worked well with the material
and further proved that she's a rising star
in the world of sci-fi and horror. Notably,
this was arguably her biggest role to date,
as it placed her front and center as
a co-lead in a big budget blockbuster.
65 might not go down in history as one of 2023's
most acclaimed movies, but Barbie is arguably a
generation-defining blockbuster. In addition to
being one of this year's most successful movies,
both commercially and critically, Greta Gerwig's
hit proved that auteur visions can appeal
to mainstream audiences. Ariana Greenblatt
plays a standout part in the movie as Sasha,
an angsty Gen Z teen who lost interest
in playing with dolls a long time ago.
Sasha is one of the main human
characters in Barbie. The titular
doll comes to the human world
to find Sasha's mother, Gloria,
a disgruntled Mattel employee who's trying to
find her purpose in life. Initially, though,
Barbie thinks she's coming to help the teen.
Sasha and Gloria don't always see eye-to-eye,
and their relationship is at the heart of some
of the film's funniest and most dramatic scenes.
"Are you really going to let Barbie take you
and your tween daughter to an imaginary land?"
"Yes, and you wanna know why?
Because I never get to do anything."
For Greenblatt, portraying the Gen
Z'er was an opportunity for her to
play an authentic teenage girl on the
screen. She told the Hollywood Reporter:
"I tried to at least make [Sasha] as relatable
as possible. I wanted to represent teenage girls
appropriately. No one understands a teenage
girl unless you were one once in your life."
Ariana Greenblatt's next feature film role
will see her return to familiar ground,
as she's set to play Tiny Tina in Eli Roth's
upcoming Borderlands adaptation. The sci-fi
actioner will chronicle the adventures of
a band of misfits as they travel across an
alien-infested planet to find the daughter
of one of the most important people in the
universe. In addition to aliens, the heroes
will also have to contend with bandits,
savages, and the other villainous
deviants who populate the planet.
It remains to be seen how each character will be
portrayed in the movie, but Tina, Greenblatt's
character, has been described as "feral." Indeed,
this might be her most unhinged role to date,
and it's bound to showcase a whole new side
of her acting sensibilities. Furthermore,
with Roth at the helm, coupled with the
source material that inspired the movie,
this is bound to be a violent affair with
plenty of dark humor thrown into the mix.
For Borderlands, Greenblatt will be joined by
an all-star cast that includes Cate Blanchett,
Jack Black, Jamie Lee Curtis,
Kevin Hart, and many more.
Unfortunately, Borderlands won't be released
until next August. Following Ahsoka, though,
it's only a matter of time until Ariana Greenblatt
appears in even more high-profile projects.